Bà bảo mắc cấp, và hành thông xuất, phương tất hiệu quả.
Trong hợp trung bị hướng chính hợp, mong t chế, xây dịch các nền tạm dùng trong phân bộ môn được lợp và kìm chá vừa tự gạch.
Các bình là cấp, tại cách, đợp mối mạnh mẽ hơn nữa, phương tức lấy đạo chỉ là điều hành,
cũng thành ngoan trụ chương tộc trích không ra phát triển, điều phố mối lực.
Nằm bảo điều biện cho cậu xá và trụ chế dạ về cấp quả của bán.
Cậu xá là tính nào của hành trị cơm, chực tiếp tự thị, phụ vụ hành ra, quả vấn đề và xin tự thị tìm của xong,
lúc cầu của người dân và rân dạy.
Giờ hỏi cậu xá, với được xây dịch đủ sức hóa trị,
xức phát triển, chúng không làm thầy để phương cấp tình, không có mối vụ cậu xá,
có thể làm tốt, thì con việu của cấp xã tận khó,
tự thị chưa làm mạo, thầm quyền nhấn lực,
tại chính những con cuộc mọi người dẫn thì cấp tình của trình nhẹm khóc gửi của gái nước không để tổn lòng.
Tự thị gấp xã sự hay lòng của người dân, sinh nhẹm,
là thức đau hiệu quả mà đau khu cải hướng.